[Music]
all right let's go to jennifer in
orlando what's up jennifer
how are you doctor john we were rocking
on this morning how about you
i'm doing okay
awesome so how can i help
no awesome i take that back okay it's
not awesome
i kind of just appreciate it i kind of
say awesome about every positivity
honestly no i need to back that thing up
so you said okay and i'll say oh what's
going on jennifer
no i appreciate the positivity i need it
well it can be a little bit toxic
sometimes so what's up man
um so my brother he just returned from a
deployment overseas
and i believe that he's having a mental
health crisis and he
does not want me to tell my parents how
old is he
he is 27.
and
so a little bit of background i moved to
florida
and basically my whole family followed
me here
you said that with like and they're like
my
my son will say his little sister keeps
following him around you're like
that's exactly what
awesome
my whole family followed me here my
parents was about two hours away and my
brother moved into the same area as me
he's met he's married i'm married we're
only a few years apart i'm older than
him
[Music]
and he came here and he told me he's
always had mental health issues growing
up um i as far as i knew it wasn't
um it wasn't like
severe
um he had oh he was diagnosed with adhd
and
dyslexia when we were kids and he always
had trouble learning
then he went to he went into the
military he got married just a couple
like a year ago
and um he came here and he had told me
and my husband that he was diagnosed
again with adhd and they put him on
medication
and he ended up staying with us for a
month before he moved in and things
seemed okay he seemed really good him
and his wife seemed really happy and you
know things seemed really good
and one night
um
it one night it like it all like came
crashing down i
i i was home and he his wife came home
and
she said that um
i said hey where's you know where's my
brother and she's like what do you mean
i thought he was here and i was like no
he's not here
he got drunk and he came home and he got
in a car
and he was driving
his convertible drunk up and down the
highway
and he came back and he almost crashed
the car into the garage
and and i free of course i freaked out
because i've never seen him do this and
i've never seen him act like this and
he was cr he was hysterically crying and
he was you know had a meltdown and told
me that he wasn't okay that he felt
crazy
then the next the next day i confronted
him about it and he said i'm just sorry
he's like i'm so sorry you see that i
just i'm i wasn't in a good place but
i'm better now i feel okay i feel good
i'm like okay like i'll just i was like
okay uh all right you know what let me
just see how this goes yeah that was two
weeks ago and uh last night he
or uh sorry saturday night he um
went out again
and
his wife was calling him and he
disappeared
um we couldn't find him for hours until
he called my little sister who's about
10 years younger than us
to come pick him up because he's at a
gas station and his phone was dead and
he never got into the uber that his
friends called for him to go home
and
my sister picked him up and the same
thing again he was crying really
frustrated very just in
duress you could tell he was just not
okay so i
i wasn't out of town when this happened
and like i said my sister is much
younger than us so she called me and she
said hey listen
i found him do you want to talk to him
he was sober at this point so the next
day
and
the same thing i'm so sorry i did this
to you i'm so sorry um it won't happen
again i don't have again and i said hey
we need to tell
our parents
like i can't i feel like i ca i can't
help you i feel like i don't have the
tools to even support you at this point
and he got really upset and he said no
please no no
i do know that my parent my dad
especially is a trigger for him
my dad is very
he can be very hot-headed you know he's
retired law enforcement he's kind of
he can be kind of insane
and
you know
put it to put it nicely i'm only
laughing because i may know a few of
those
yes
so i don't know i don't know what to do
at this point his wife doesn't know what
to do i don't know what to do my sister
doesn't know what to do
we don't know how to move forward
well so number one
man this guy won the lottery with you as
a sister
good for you it's
awesome and
good for you for several things one for
being somebody that he trusts and being
somebody that loves him
and
not
knowing enough to know i need to do
something and i want to make sure i do
this right so good for you on all counts
that's awesome
um
i have found that returning veterans are
some of the best in on the planet
at
putting on a brave face until that face
literally that mask literally melts off
their their body
and when you said things just seemed
really good
i can't tell you how many times i've
heard that exact phrase
on the front end of
a
combat veteran
imploding
things seem so good until they just
aren't
and i think it's because there's such a
culture and there's just a necessity
right i i don't you don't if someone's
shooting at you or you are busy
protecting fill in the blank you know i
don't have time for my feelings right
now i got to keep everybody alive it
doesn't mean the feelings go away they
just
they just extract under pressure and get
get stronger and stronger really until
they finally implode
um your instinct is right the things you
just told me make me very concerned for
your brother
and
i would look at all like you hear me say
all the time behavior is a language he
is screaming for somebody to help him
and the words he's using are i'm all
cool everything's fine
you know they're not fine i know they're
not fine everyone around him knows
they're not fine
and i also want to honor the fact that
your dad's not a safe place
and that some of the
childhood stuff
you know he's been on a trajectory for a
long long time
and so
here's how i would handle that if i were
you
i would get his wife and get you and
your little sister
and i would circle up and say here's
your options number one we are calling
somebody
whether that's the va
whether that's a local um
counseling resources and one of us is
going with you probably his wife would
be best unless he asks you specifically
to come
but this isn't a
we're thinking about it this is gonna
happen
and so you have some options as to
if you just absolutely one thousand
percent say no va no va nova and i've
met a few folks there great i'll support
you on that
um
if you say no to these things then i
then you have exceeded my capacity to
help you and i'm gonna reach out to to
mom i'm gonna reach out to i'm gonna
call 9-1-1 on you because you're not
safe and right now you're being not safe
you're going to hurt somebody else too
right
and so i would frame it in you get to
choose which which call i make but i'm
making a call and if you choose to not
make a call then i'm going to default to
what i know
and actually you know what i after i say
that a lot i'm going to take back what i
just said i don't think your dad's a
good idea i
don't
and that may be your safest place but i
would reach out to a professional
community right now whether that's a
psychologist a counselor somebody who
specializes with veterans in your area
or somebody or somebody at the va you
say he's not okay right now
okay
um
he needs people to love him beyond what
he's asking for right now
and this will be hard on you and he will
probably say things like you're screwing
me over you don't love me i asked
specifically for this you're just trying
to punish me and you're gonna have to
love him through that
and just know that on the other side of
this
he will hug you tighter than you've ever
been hugged in your life
saying thank you
okay
and maybe you and his wife and your
little sister circle up um is there
anybody else in his immediate circle
does he have one or two
um
buddies from the service that are around
that
you could reach out to also
he doesn't have anybody in the service
but we do have a pretty close um circle
of friends here okay there's about two
or three of them
i would include them and if you can get
one or two men involved i think that's
helpful too
okay my experience with veterans is that
there's something there's a just a
they just are trained hierarchical and
there's something about another guy
saying this is happening and i'm looking
in the eyes right now this is going to
happen and we want you to help
participate in what's coming but this is
happening
okay and that doesn't mean he's got to
go away for 30 days it doesn't mean he's
got to be institutional nothing like
that
he has to begin meeting with somebody
today or tomorrow
really quick okay and so okay good for
you sister god he's lucky to have you
good for you and thank you for saying
something call me back after that
conversation because it's not gonna be
easy it's gonna be hard if i say that it
may be he may just his shoulders may
drop and he may weep from a place that
he hasn't wept from a long time
um
what i will tell you is this
the other side of this whole
conversation is not making a call
not doing anything
and if he ends up
dead
if he ends up hurting somebody
it will be an
ugly trip to look in the mirror there
when you know i should have made a call
that's not why you do this i just want
to let you know on the other side of
that the about the weight of not doing
anything right now is so unreasonable
the risk
um your brother's worth loving past how
mad he's going to be
good for you good for you golly we need
more people like jennifer in the world
if you see something say something
even if it's going to be uncomfortable
even it's going to cause a mess even
it's going to cause fights and yelling
and whatever
there comes a moment when we're going to
say
i'm making a call
you can help decide where we're gonna
call but i'm making a call
i mean more people like you in the world
jennifer thank you so much for loving
your brother like you do